würdest du 5 m Unterwasser schlafen
genau das ist nämlich in Schweden im
einzigen Unterwasserhotel Europas
möglich um dorthin zu kommen muss man
mit einem Boot gefahren werden denn das
Hotel liegt mitten auf einem See oh mein
Gott da ist es da fährt meine
Gastgeberin in der Sonne weg und wir
schauen uns gemeinsam das Hotel an neben
ein paar Stühlen einem Kochfeld und
einer Toilette befindet sich ziemlich
wenig auf der ersten Etage und so
langsam machen sich die ersten Zweifel
bereit ob sich der teure Preis wirklich
gelohnt hat über eine klapprige Treppe
steigt man dann fünf Meter unter Wasser
in den Zimmer in dem zwei einzelne
Betten stehen und überall Fenster meine
rum sind leider waren die Scheiben sehr
dreckig hallo Mister der kostet 2000 das
Bett nicht besonders bequem seit eher so
Jugendherbergen Flair und die
Taschenlampe die eigentlich dafür
gedacht war um in das dunkle Wasser rein
zu leuchten und Fische zu sehen hatte
keinen Akku leer dafür hat man die
Möglichkeit ein Abend komplett von allen
anderen Menschen abgeschottet zu sein
den Abend komplett alleine zu verbringen
und das habe ich tatsächlich sehr
genossen für mich jedoch nicht die 350 €
pro Nacht werden aber jetzt die Frage an